其他人：是真的会
Others: It's true, it really works.
Alice: 不知道呢哈哈哈
Alice: I don't know, haha.
其他人：哎那个答题是必玩环节吗
Others: Hey, is the quiz part mandatory?
Lucia: 哈喽我又下来了
Lucia: Hello, I'm back down here.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 哈哈你的知识
Alice: Haha, your knowledge...
其他人：我觉得贫瘠
Others: I think it's lacking.
其他人：尤其环保方面
Others: Especially in environmental topics.
其他人：我特别贫
Others: I'm particularly poor in that.
Alice:那你就瞎猜嘛
Alice: Then just guess randomly.
其他人：好吧
Others: Okay.
Alice: 好吧好吧
Alice: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 没事你知道我们题目的灵感之后
Lucia: It's fine, once you know the inspiration behind our questions...
Lucia: 你就会觉得
Lucia: You'll understand.
Alice: 你至少保证给我对一个好吗
Alice: At least promise me to get one right, okay?
Alice: 要不然你怎么赎回我
Alice: Otherwise, how are you going to redeem me?
其他人：咦有什么可说
Others: Eh, what's there to say?
其他人：你在这呆着哈哈哈
Others: Just stay here, haha.
Alice: 什么意思
Alice: What do you mean?
Tasha: 53号楼在哪里啊
Tasha: Where is building 53?
Tasha: 53
Tasha: 53?
Alice: 嗯不知道呢
Alice: Hmm, I don't know.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 你可以找一些
Alice: You can find some...
Alice: 两个
Alice: Two...
Alice: 没事你找三个也行
Alice: It's okay, you can find three as well.
Alice: 三四个给别人留一点
Alice: Three or four, leave some for others.
其他人：早知道刚才真的有一大包
Others: If I knew earlier, there was a big bag just now.
Tasha: 哪儿呢这么不堪
Tasha: Where? It's so unbearable.
其他人：我都藏里了
Others: I hid it all.
Alice: 你真6啊
Alice: You're really something.
Lucia: 哦我们那一包竟然没放起来
Lucia: Oh, we didn't even put that bag away.
Alice: 哈哈哈他找着那一包
Alice: Haha, he found that bag.
Alice: 然后跟我说这游戏结束了哈哈
Alice: And then told me the game was over, haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Alice: 喂你想坐这个是吗
Alice: Hey, you want to sit here, right?
Alice: 嗯我不让你坐
Alice: Hmm, I won't let you sit.
Alice: 你怎么想
Alice: What do you think?
Alice: 你怎么不看我鞋底下有没呢
Alice: Why don't you check under my shoes?
其他人：你抬起来我看看啊
Others: Lift your foot, let me see.
Alice: 有我跟你姓好吧
Alice: I'll take your surname, alright?
Alice: 来来来来来来
Alice: Come on, come on, come on, come on
Alice:真都假都
Alice: Real or fake
Lucia: （歌词）are you still here
Lucia: (lyrics) are you still here
Lucia: （歌词）making the sound checking me junk
Lucia: (lyrics) making the sound checking me junk
Katrina: 我好像又忘记回问题了
Katrina: I think I forgot to answer the question again
Katrina: 以后禁止用你乐队的微博点赞我微博
Katrina: From now on, you are not allowed to use your band's Weibo to like my Weibo posts
Katrina: 哈哈哎
Katrina: Haha, hey
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 哎这怎么还在这
Lucia: Hey, why is this still here
Katrina: 没事不想云逛展了
Katrina: It's nothing, I don't want to browse the virtual exhibition anymore
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello, hi
Shure: 哎好
Shure: Hey, okay
Shure: 我马上下来取一下
Shure: I'll come down to get it right away
Alice: 不知道呢
Alice: I don't know
其他人：你会说口语吗
Others: Can you speak English?
其他人：哦曾经会过
Others: Oh, I used to
其他人：那你得会一周之前会过
Others: Well, you should have been able to a week ago
其他人：我可以现在one哨子学一下
Others: I can learn it now with one whistle
其他人：我是什么
Others: What am I
Jake:你是
Jake: You are
其他人：recall一下
Others: Recall it
其他人：recall
Others: Recall
其他人：旅游会没有人用过这口语
Others: No one uses this English while traveling
Jake:用我用过
Jake: I used it
Jake:只是你现在好像看起来可以搞一下这个东西
Jake: It just looks like you can handle this thing now
Jake:lookslike我会了
Jake: Looks like I got it
Jake:哎以后开开开的电脑吧
Jake: Hey, let's open the computer in the future
Jake:也还有
Jake: There are still
其他人：月光哎
Others: Moonlight, hey
Lucia: 是好准哈哈哈哈
Lucia: It's so accurate, hahaha
其他人：你只需要弹前三个音我就知道了
Others: You only need to play the first three notes and I know it
Jake:是哪个调一下
Jake: Which key is it
Lucia: 那我换一个前三个音
Lucia: Then I'll change the first three notes
其他人：换一个我就不会了
Others: If you change it, I won't know it
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
其他人：这个很会
Others: This one is easy
Lucia: 这应该也会
Lucia: This one should be easy too
Lucia: 哎我觉得我和弦好像弹错了
Lucia: Hey, I think I played the chord wrong
Lucia: 啊这是对的
Lucia: Ah, this is correct
Lucia: 忘了不会背谱子
Lucia: I forgot, I can't memorize the score.
其他人：哎，你们用过2楼这个吗
Others: Have you guys used the second floor?
Shure: 用过
Shure: Yeah, we have.
其他人：我已经开了
Others: I've already opened it.
Shure: 他每次都
Shure: Every time he...
Jake:校准
Jake: Calibrate it.
其他人：哦他怎么跟一楼不太一样
Others: Oh, why is it different from the first floor?
其他人：一楼那个就是傻瓜呀
Others: The one on the first floor is just dummy-proof.
其他人：就是就是
Others: Yeah, exactly.
其他人：两步一结束他就每次都要
Others: After two steps, he has to...
Shure: 他就每次都要校准
Shure: He has to calibrate it every time.
Jake:它校准有更好的校准方法吗
Jake: Is there a better way to calibrate it?
其他人：手动校准
Others: Manual calibration.
其他人：你叫的好准啊
Others: You calibrated it so precisely.
其他人：建建议以后你来跟我标术语
Others: Maybe you should help me mark the terms next time.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahaha.
其他人：校的好准
Others: So precise.